workers who are looking after them right
after that anthony
charlie dagetta in london thanks charlie
here in the u.s
if you need a more stark example of how
bad the pandemic is
take a look at this we have just
recorded the second highest single
day death toll since the pandemic began
nearly 2600 people lost their lives
we're also seeing progress this morning
toward a cdc
recommendation on who should get the
vaccine first
once it's approved in this country our
lead national correspondent david begno
is in indianapolis this morning david
good morning
good morning so slightly different here
anthony the cdc is saying listen let's
give it to healthcare workers first and
then
folks in long-term care facilities like
the elderly
notably in the conversation i had with
the cdc yesterday they said we not only
want to give it to doctors and nurses
but
also like the custodians who are
cleaning the rooms removing the waste
they're just as much at risk as the
doctors and nurses here's more from our
conversation
the fact that we have a limited supply
means that we have to be very selective
in who
we give this to meet dr jose romero he
is chairman of the committee at the cdc
that is making these recommendations
which will affect all of us
among those selected for group 1a are
front-line medical personnel
and seniors living in long-term care
facilities the reasons we have
selected these two groups are are based
in science they're based in equitable
distribution of vaccine and maximizing
benefit
and minimizing harm according to cdc
analysis there are about 3 million
people living in long-term care
facilities
then there are roughly 21 million health
care personnel including
non-medical custodial and administrative
staff
who will also get the vaccine first and
that's about 24 million people
in just group 1a both vaccines
are going to require two doses several
weeks apart
so that's roughly 50 million doses for
just those two groups of people
right now there's only about 40 million
doses available
so that means most of us most americans
will still have to wait several months
for a shot in the arm
according to former cdc director dr tom
frieden
companies are ambitious in what they say
they can produce and we hope they're
right
but remember earlier this year we were
told there would be 300 million doses by
the end of the year
then 45 million than 40 million so it's
been a shrinking number it's still an
amazing close to miraculous
accomplishment
but we can't let optimism get in the way
of
reality given all this information the
reality is the pandemic is far from over
and it's taking
an emotional toll on frontline
healthcare workers like dr scott samlin
he's an er doctor in hammond indiana
just outside chicago
we spoke to him at the very beginning of
the pandemic in march and this is what
he said
this is the most scared i've ever been
being an er doctor i spoke to him again
yesterday
and every day is groundhog's day there's
only so many 12-hour shifts you can do
in a week
go home sleep sanitize yourself and go
back for more i mean
this is just a marathon and every day
it's the same code with patients
people sick people aren't ventilators
people dying
scott said the infections that are
coming into his clinic more people are
infected he said even more than
hospitalizations and deaths david it's
just
off the page how many people are walking
in and are positive
before we go let's talk about the
dakotas i mean there is just an
explosion of covet there take north
dakota for example
one of our colleagues went and got video
of the line of people waiting to get
tested in north dakota they do it once a
week it is free in fact the person who
runs
the health agency there told us i could
do it every day i just don't have the
staff to do it
gail one in four people in north dakota